d ちーへ ca
いい a はい
me
それじゃあねっ幸手ございましたこちら
車に貼るようの機ずついきましたステッカーではいというわけで私耳よりの情報の後輩
が消えてしまいました
はい自分でてたんですが僕は悪くありませ自分の力自らの声でやれば定例を押しました
こちら
天童市たーーー
車がもう酒に来るから
[音楽]
ブーブなんですけどーつけっ
くっちゃんときません皆さん彼は自分の口でくれよ
ん
いいましたおめでとうございます怖いだけど結構昔から使っている人はもう族は開華て
言ったんでこのたちの遊んでやろうかなと思いますというわけで今日の動画はシンプル
に強いの雲ボックほぼずっとずたらめっちゃ目たね知ってみようと思います
かぼちゃをシールでねむねむとさすがにあの揉め事になりそうなんでこんなに3年前で
これ三昧ついてんだいつもやっぱり山に毎月じゃんこれえ待って2枚どころじゃない
まっちょちょっとポッ
一番する140発の傷4近く30枚あるから
12001200だ今から公園で車に約1900個の手術をつけていきたいとおもい
まして際に後輩とずっと家にいるので車乗ってないんですよこれなんで多分そんなに車
の長外壁と確認してないんで気づいたら誰かにボコられてたみたいな空気感出して後半
ザクロ2200発3曲続けていこうと思いますテレカ m
[音楽]
確か法律的にその取れないステッカー貼ってる分には問題無かったぜ2点する時何でも
の完成しちゃったらそのままボロボロのんだけど車で走っちゃっていただいても構い
ませんそれなら車買い替えることはそれでいいんじゃねぇまである人間に並べてみよう
か
すごい多いけど大丈夫なんこれを心配なってきてこの良質に貼れるかん
そして後でこれね開けて宮司に気づいたんですけど微妙に違うんですよ全部
すごくいいなんか微妙に違うんですよねこれまずでであるかも知れこれ
[音楽]
あああああこれあこれ
あーこれ
を覆えばまあ離婚ヌード直行もーっと思ってると思うんですよ
開会とりあってこのブルマーと泳げ最後にしっかりという
傷つけて終わらせようと思いますねば
作業回数
と静かにやっていきます松は銃弾から黒いメッキでも剥がれるぞ中
じいろなぜ車って貼っとくだけでも
[音楽]
まあ普通にあ泣いてるみたいに見えるはこんな感じちょっと貼っていくこともや
ちょっと次爪貼ってみましょうか
こういうところがめっちゃ得られてそうなイメージ
あうんぽいぽいぽいぽ一派だっ
10時に気づいたんですけれどじゃあこの傷がめっちゃリアですねこれ全部あるとかた
リアリティなくなりそうなのでいい感じの絶妙なラインで編んできますね
傷の多さフェイができるのであるっ
本当がくれたらん
りすぎたかなちょっと映像から分かんないですけどねあーから見ると数めっちゃ傷つい
てくるものってことですその他のこんなもんでいいでしょう回続いた横でガーッと
こんなに各数名が横に聞いて名取数出せればいいなと思います
me
ああああああ
[音楽]
入ってあげて再度完成しましたいかがでしょやっ結構やっと車が傷つくっていうと
サイドに明治館で相当疲れてました
いやーいいだなぁ時過ぎて前ぐらいな感じだと思いますとも結構リアルです
もう
王道なんだけど日本ステーキですが持っていきましょう次は後ろですそれは正直
綺麗にはあんまり
超ないんで鬼没程度に全体のバランスをとるで覚えておきましょう
ん
[音楽]
[拍手]
なんかグッズ階段から降りてくるから杏ちゃん way も見られる合わせから
デビューも一応貼っておきます
[音楽]
パートに分けてください
戦士ましたこちらが食べ1200も入れなかったですね
だいたいでもさん400傷黒でつけることができました後輩の車でございます本当に
本当めっちゃくちゃ1200枚ベタベタ貼ろうとしたんですけどもイク痙攣だったら
リアリティーを求めたいなということでリアルにありそうな傷の限界のかつにしてみ
ました
うスロと上も5をちょっとだけ貼ってと絡められて
も長期突いているようには見せてありますから前と違うだけめっちゃ本気備蓄つけて
参加したのでこの車を見たた後輩はどういう反応するのでしょ
多分なんですけど近くで見るとさすがに親父は彼らってホントあのここここから降りて
きた時の反応次第だと思いますではターゲットを選んでみましょう
ん
買い出しに浮かせるみたいに買い出しで車乗ってちょっと張って来てっていう理想の
いいかがで呼び出すて急いで帰ってくるまで起きたら今度様といろいろ果たしてどう
いう花を入れてくれるのでしょ
きゃってはいきましょう
おっ
[音楽]
えっ
終わってヤバいって普通にあっ
なんせいっ
要望
やれるんじゃよ
う
[音楽]
ブーブーエロ
たっっあった
ポイトっ
aname
いったーーー悪いたあー住民がに行くなり焼くなり好きにいって言うからまあまあ
こんな女と ji ありがとうござい上げどうよあーりん定時以降呂蒙一新して格好
未だですねこれ
俗にいう痛車数分出張 c だけだよじゃあ今から行ったらなんかもうこのままでいい
みたいはである
ナイコレなにこれ撃ち抜かれちゃう貼ってなされた
あー3つは危険なおねっと雪でキンスキーが目を離さん
すればボコボコにされる特急出たーーーーー
立ってくれる方ご清聴